ich habe 200.000 € in eine Idee
investiert aus der diese App geworden
ist die ab heute überall verfügbar ist
also scannt diesen QR Code oder klickt
auf den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und ladet euch save it
jetzt herunter wäht den Creator Code
Dave aus und fangt an bares Geld beim
onlinees shopppen zu sparen wir sind
mega happy und freuen uns über jeden
einzelnen der uns supportet denn je mehr
Leute wir von euch im Rücken haben desto
bessere Cashback Deals können wir für
jeden von euch herausholen also lasst
alles stehen und liegen und sagt
Freunden Familie und wem auch immer
Bescheid denn einige Shops haben sich
nicht lumpen lassen und zum Release
unserer App extra zeitlich begrenzte
special deals rausgehauen worüber wir
mega happy sind dazu würden wir uns
riesig über eine Fünf Sterne Bewertung
im PlayStore im App Store und wo auch
immer freuen wenn euch die App gefällt
und jetzt will ich euch aber nicht
weiter aufhalten denn was alles in den
letzten wenigen Tagen vor Release
passiert ist warum wir mit 6 Millionen
Euro schon vor relelease der App
bewertet sind und was 7 ver damit zu tun
hat erfahrt ihr in diesem Video im
Prinzip waren die letzten Monate einfach
nur ein Rennen gegen die Zeit jeder von
uns hat jeden Tag 7 Tage die Woche
mindestens 12 Stunden gearbeitet und
dazu muss man wissen dass ich ja auch
noch ein fünfköpfiges Team für meine
Youtube Videos betreue und Zuschauer
darauf warten hochwertige Videos von mir
zu sehen bedeutet ab März für mich
Doppelschicht um irgendwie alles
gleichzeitig zu handändeln und weil die
Zeit ab März absolut geflogen ist habe
ich mich irgendwann mit meinem besten
Mann cataleo nichts verwechseln mit
katalea am Frankfurter Flughafen wieder
gefunden um für die nächsten vier Wochen
die Jungs in Kanada bei der Produktion
von Seven vsus wild zu unterstützen
wirklich das Letzte was ich in dem
Moment gebraucht habe war diese prod
tion weil noch nicht klar war ob wir
wirklich zu unserem releaseedum Anfang
November mit der App fertig würden erst
aber als ich in Kanada angekommen bin
habe ich gemerkt was diese vier Wochen
wirklich für eine Auswirkung auf mich
und mein Startup haben in Kanada sind
wir durchgehend 9 Stunden vor der Zeit
durch die Zeitverschiebung wenn die
Jungs in Deutschland also ihren Laptop
aufklappen gehe ich abends schlafen und
ich bin ja nicht ohne Grund in Kanada
ich bin da um 7 vs wild bei der
Produktion zu unterstützen was ein
riesen Projekt ist bedeutet ich muss mit
Kopf Körper und voller Arbeitsleistung
bei der Produktion sein und selbst wenn
ich gewollt H hätte wä keine Zeit und
kein Platz für die Arbeit an meinem
Startup gewesen und plötzlich habe ich
gedacht das war vermutlich die
schlechteste Entscheidung für mich und
mein Startup in dass ich mein gesamtes
Erspartes gesteckt habe bis ich eines
Abends Max und Johannes von diesem
Problem erzählt habe bis dato wussten
die beiden noch gar nicht was ich in den
letzten Monaten im Hintergrund da so
fabriziert habe und zu meinem Glück
haben die Jungs relativ schnell das
Potenzial der App erkannt und relativ
schnell haben wir überlegt wie Synergien
zwischen seven VSS wild und meinem
Startup aussehen können und haben eine
Lösung gefunden ich verzichte auf Teile
meiner Bezahlung für den Monat
Auslandsproduktion für Seven vs wild und
die Jungs bekommen einen besonders guten
Deal mit save it damit wir placements in
Haupt und die Hal the scen Serie von
7even Verss wild einbinden können das
heißt nicht dass ihr weniger spart wenn
ihr den Code 7 Verss wild benutzt
sondern viel mehr dass der Code 7 Verss
wild bei den Leuten die ihn auswählen
länger bestehen bleibt als bei ein
normalen Code denn das ist noch wichtig
für alle Creator hinzuzufügen genau wie
beim Fortnite und beim CoD Creator Code
löscht sich der Creator Code bei den
Nutzern nach gewisser Zeit automatisch
und Sie müssen daran erinnert werden
diesen Creator Code zu erneuern hält
zwei Wochen kostet euch kein Cent und
ist sehr geiler Support dazu muss man
sagen 7even Verss wild kommuniziert ja
nur einmal im Jahr also einmal im Jahr
kommt eine neue Staffel das bedeutet Sie
haben gar nicht die Möglichkeit alle
paar Wochen die Nutzer daran zu erinnern
den Creator Code zu erneuern deswegen
wir Ihnen da mit dieser märik etwas
entgegengekommen sind am Ende war genau
das nicht nur ein riesen
Vertrauensvorschuss von Max und Johannes
worüber ich mega dankbar bin weil sie zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht mal die App
gesehen hatten sondern gleichzeittig
auch die Lösung für unser hennei Problem
aus der letzten Folge wir konnten also
die größte Creator Serienproduktion
jemals davon überzeugen direkt zum
Release bei uns in der App dabei zu sein
und ab diesem Zeitpunkt kamen täglich
neue Shops hinzu was mega gut ist aber
in unserer App eben nur die halbe Miete
ein Blick ins Creator Postfach hat uns
diesen Stress aber auch noch genommen
und die wochenlangen monatelangen
Gespräche haben sich bezahlt gemacht und
immer mehr Creator haben zugesagt und
dieser Knoten dieses riesen Henne eiprem
womit wir uns über Monate
herumgeschlagen haben war endlich gelöst
und wir konnten anfangen richtig zu
arbeiten und dieses Interesse an Shops
und creatorn ging auch nicht spurlos an
Investoren vorbei jetzt könnte man sich
fragen warum zur Hölle brauchen wir
einen Investor ich habe ja Geld
investiert und das haben wir auch mit
Sicherheit noch nicht ausgegeben dafür
hole ich etwas weiter aus dominik ist
eine absolute Maschine wenn es um
Weitsicht in unserem Startup geht klar
ich denke auch viel über die Zukunft
nach und über Ideen und Ziele und so
weiter aber Dominik macht das Ganze
Objektiv aufgrund von Daten und Fakten
in diesen konkreten Fall heißt das wie
viel kosten haben wir wie entwickeln
sich unsere Kosten wie viel mehr
Manpower brauchen wir wie viel
Notgroschen brauchen wir wenn irgendwas
nicht nach Plan läuft und so weiter im
absolut schlimmsten Fall würde unser
Geld bis März 2024 reichen und jetzt
könnte man sagen h dann habt ihr ja noch
über ein halbes Jahr Zeit ja kann man so
sehen wir haben uns aber trotzdem dafür
entschieden einen Investor zu suchen und
das aus folgendem Grund sucht man erst
einen Investor wenn das Geld schon fast
leer ist steht man quasi mit dem Rücken
zur Wand und hat überhaupt keine
Möglichkeit vernünftig zu verhandeln
geschweige denn den Deal abzulehnen der
nicht so gut ist dass alle Parteien
happy sind und das ist das Letzte was
wir wollen bei einer Menge Start-ups
führt nämlich genau dieser Punkt zum
schealern also haben wir uns für den
sicheren Weg entschieden und einen
Investor gesucht glücklicherweise hat
sich unser Startup irgendwie schon ein
bisschen rumgesprochen und wir hatten
mehr Angebote als wir annehmen kommen am
Ende haben wir uns für jemanden
entschieden der wirklich ein großes
Netzwerk und viel Expertise aus einem
relevanten Bereich mitbringt was die
absolute Traumvorstellung ist nach ein
bisschen hin und her kennenlernen
Potenziale aufzeigen und vielen
Gesprächen haben wir einen Deal gefunden
der für alle gepasst hat 195 000 €
Investment in Form eines wandeldarlehens
da gehe ich jetzt nicht rein das würde
den Rahmen hier komplett sprengen für
3,25% was eine Bewertung von genau 6
Millionen EUR vor Release der App ergibt
womit wir und ich glaube auch der
Investor mega happy sind aber plötzlich
ist man nicht mehr nur noch ein Team aus
vier Gründern die irgendwie deep
invested sind sondern es ist ein
Investor dabei der das natürlich auch
alles cool findet der aber auch
Ergebnisse sehen will abseits von all
diesen Gefühlen völlig egal ob Euphorie
Respekt was auch immer aber natürlich
eine mega Bestätigung von uns die uns im
Entwicklungs Prozess noch mal einen
richtigen ablift gegeben und es tut mir
schrecklich leid dass ich euch die
ganzen Potenziale und tollen Ideen auf
deren Basis der Investor diese Bewertung
gemacht hat noch nicht erzählen kann
aber diese Videos werden einfach von zu
vielen Leuten gesehen die vielleicht
auch ein eigenes Unternehmen haben das
in eine ähnliche Richtung geht und auch
gute Entwickler haben wir haben einfach
zu viel Schiss dass Leute uns zu
vorkommen weil wir hier irgendwelche
Ideen ausplaudern aber seid euch sicher
es kommt noch eine ganze ganze Menge und
das ist erst der Anfang und mit dieser
Euphorie und Bestätigung konnten wir uns
endlich wieder unsere eigentlichen
Aufgabe widmen nämlich das Produkt bis
zum Release fertig zu bekommen die Tage
flogen an uns vorbei aus Wochenenden
wurden ganz normale Arbeitstage dann 135
Tage nach der Firmengründung 223 Tage
nach der ersten Idee alleine nachts im
Bett nach 200.000 € Investment von mir
nach 195 000 € Investment von dem
Investor ist es tatsächlich soweit die
App ist komplett kostenlos in allen
AppStores ab jetzt für euch verfügbar
save it ist endlich kein Projekt aus dem
Hinterzimmer mehr sondern gehört uns als
Community und darauf bin ich mächtig
stolz das ist wirklich völlig
unglaublich also Ernst das ist völlig
verrückt und es fällt eine Menge Menge
Menge Last von mir ab das ist wirklich
mein ganzes Erspartes das ist kein
Scheiß den ich hier erzählt habe mal
wieder ein kompletter allingang von mir
ich bin
unheimlich stolz auf diese App ich finde
das komplett geisteskrank wie die
aussieht ich finde das komplett krank
was die Jungs für eine Arbeit geleistet
haben egal ob bei mir im Team für die
Youtube Videos wo Nächte durchgepaukt
wurden und vielen Dank auch für das
ganze Feedback bei den Jungs im SAV Team
komplett geisteskrank 6 Monate Kopf
runter komplett durchgehackt ich bin
mächtig mächtig stolz auf jeden der
daran teilgenommen hat und möchte mich
auch bei jedem einzelnen von euch
bedanken der sich tatsächlich die Mühe
macht die App herunterzuladen uns
Feedback dazulassen die zu benutzen und
dabei zu helfen das Ding richtig groß zu
machen also vielen vielen Dank an jeden
einzelnen von euch komm fast die Tränen
Alter ah ja also ein letztes Mal ladet
euch die App über diesen QR Code oder
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
runter lasst uns Feedback da lasst uns
fün Sterne im App Store da vielen Dank
wir sehen uns in 7 Tagen wieder und
schauen wie viele von euch das
tatsächlich gemacht haben und wie der
Release so lief vielen Dank für das
Begleiten dieses
[Musik]
Projektes